hey guys how's it no no no stop saying
hey guys I'm not allowed to say it from
here on in that's a lie because I'm
probably gonna keep saying it but do you
guys have a suggestion for a better
intro please leave me a comment
did you ask IJ you guys ask me questions
and I answer them starting off here
we've got Kiera them at Dyea mented
asking when did I realise that I was a
woman well did you like like a movie was
the best movie you've ever seen and yes
honest to goodness gracious it was the
best movie I've ever seen
ah I mean I've seen a lot of really
great movies but this movie was so good
it was so cute I just absolutely loved
it from the soundtrack to the cast of
people that they had for the voices -
how freaking cute it is and I absolutely
love Legos so this was like the perfect
movie in the whole entire world and it
was so cute if you haven't seen it
please go see it if you haven't liked
the video game play the game or see the
movie cuz playing the game is like
seeing the movie I don't know it's so
good so cute I love it it's cool to be a
part of a team speaking of songs when
I'm recording my first album I've
actually been talking about recording an
album for probably like four years now
talking about it to myself mostly to my
sister a lot she always asks me I said
you starting your album you know like
yeah I started on that yeah I started I
thought about it I thought about it the
first step to doing anything is thinking
about it so I've done a lot of thinking
Bobby wants no power off to learning to
speak today I whole often I use Google
glass my Google glass actually broke I
don't know what happened I think somehow
intransitive traveling it just stopped
working I the Google glass Explorer
program they're allowing you to trade in
your old glass to get the glass - so
mine is currently being I don't know
it's somewhere somewhere in the world
hopefully I will get it back yeah what
am i listening to an audible calm /
iJustine so those of you guys who may be
new here who may be a part of the I J
likes book club I have an audible.com
slash iJustine code that will give you
one free download 30-day trial they've
so many freaking ebooks to pick from and
if you
never done an audiobook I promise you it
will change your life because it changed
in my life I love to read but I don't
have time to read so I started listening
to these books when I travel when I
Drive in the shower just coolest thing
ever I honestly can't stress it enough
like I am obsessed I'm currently looking
for a new book that I should have read
to me so let me know what you guys think
I just finished divergent series I can't
wait for the movie to come out I think
he comes out in March actually who would
you be able to survive a zombie
apocalypse I'm convinced that I would
not be able to survive because I barely
survived three weeks of being sick with
the flu
throwing zombies in the mix having to
fight being sick trying to just fight
off illness and zombies no no I am a I
am um I can't even
no I can't can't snuggle it is asking if
I'd ever consider being a beauty guru
it's actually really funny that you ask
that because before this I filmed a
video of how I curl my hair I'm gonna be
posting that soon I would never consider
being a beauty guru it's not really my
thing I mean I do love fashion there's a
way that I can kind of tie that all into
stuff that I'm already doing and sort of
my style but I don't want to be a guru
cos I don't want to be I can do what I
want I do what I want what I want with
my body do what I want won't stop not
solve this riddle come on I don't want
to solve any riddles a cloud rises up to
one cloud and then gets puffy to eight
clouds how high did the cloud go no I do
my trick questions
do you like Law & Order Special Victims
Unit I do it's like my favorite show
ever
pretty much my dream come true to be a
dead body on that show I know want to
maybe get another cameo but have more of
a role and not die maybe I want to kill
I want to kill that's what I want to do
I want to be the one that kills what's
the work on that Laura one said if I
posted with I will post I cannot
freaking read this is like my first IJ
back in a long time and I don't know how
to read the thing for audible they don't
have to read
I need bifocals do you wanna build a
snowman asks over eight eight eight I
don't want to build a snowman I don't
like the snow I actually haven't seen
frozen but I did see that the shaycarl
video where his little daughter was
singing the do you wanna build a snowman
song it's seriously like I almost cried
I was like urine freakin cute I can't
even stand it
Conor but tight fist wants to note my
first impressions of Canada were Canada
impressions it was cold it was so cold
that I was mildly actually very
miserable to be honest with you I would
love to go back when it's not freezing
cold
I don't really get to see anything kind
of explored their underground ish places
there's anywhere that I can Vail where I
didn't have to actually go outside I was
there
well I doesn't free post YouTube videos
I'm just like I don't know she's busy at
her job and I think she forgot her
password Diego Muniz what TV series if I
wouldn't watching lately this whole
talking thing struggle I just caught up
on revolution season two I really like
this show and I love that it's kind of
found its own the first season was kind
of a little bit all over the place but
now the character development has been
amazing I really really like it I also
just finish up season one of under the
dome so good now I need to watch house
of cards I didn't even watch the first
season so I need to watch 1 & 2 which
I'm pretty excited about cuz I can just
watch it back-to-back one season two
season
done cassadee whenever I was to compete
in an Olympic sport what would it be
I'm not gonna lie if I did compete in
sleeping I would probably win I love to
sleep I could wake up all night asleep
go to sleep again sleep all day like I
could sleep through anything I've slept
through earthquakes I slept through fire
alarms she's probably really dangerous
thankfully there was no fires but I am
so good at sleeping feel like somebody
asked me a question about the Olympics
yeah there it is that's if I was
watching the Winter Olympics and I have
not watched a single thing nothing I've
just not even clips on YouTube which
kind of although I haven't following all
of the Penguins that have been playing
in the Olympics so I've been kind of
following each of those players and
their teams respectively but other than
that that is about as far as it goes if
you consider reading what the Bucks
tweets about the Olympic
I don't know what he's talking about I
haven't tweeted him I'm like dude I have
no idea what you're saying like you're
speaking some other language about some
other world that I really don't know
about connect to brings us to the end of
this episode of ask IJ make sure you
guys subscribe
I had these awesome clothes from throw
boy I love him he makes such cute things
and my god this is so great my dreams
have come true okay poo see you later
I'll see you guys later as well don't
forget to subscribe
even though subscribing I don't think
really matters anymore does it do you
guys even see subscriptions I don't know
see you later
hey guys welcome to another cooking
video today is national cherry pie day
so that can